was geht hier vor max und herzlich
willkommen zur fünften folge minecraft
nero direkt nach meiner mathe abitur
prüfung deshalb kam auch übrigens
gestern keine folge mitarbeiter übrigens
per tritt was geht keine rückmeldung
davon habe ich gehört dass andere das
problem auch schon hatten
ich hoffe mal dass mir jetzt nicht
irgendwie sowas passiert wie die anderen
was sich direkt tot bin aber ich glaube
ich hatte natürlich nicht natürlich
nicht aber ich kann euch sagen so viele
sein
das ist eine menge was bei knapp wird
das ist eine menge so lo fps des todes
22 33 27 okay es ist richtig schlecht
jetzt gerade sind 40 leute ich wollte
ich wollte ich mir sagen was sie für
heute vor habe ich habe so wenig eisen
welches ja genau patrick hat schon eine
menge vorproduziert und eine menge
geschafft league habe schon gesagt habe
so du hast dir ein haus geklärt bis in
der stadt
ich bin direkt der stadt ja ich muss
meine eigenen koordinaten screenshot
damit ist das wenigstens habe so es ist
ein bisschen stress mit der ex gerade
okay da ist ein
nichts ist da sieht man halt viel kraft
direkt geradeaus oder wie das kleine
haus rechts
da ist kein bock rechts vom vorteil das
kleine grüne häuschen okay da sind
sachen von dir drin weil ich darf mir
meine lieben freunde von patrick ein
bisschen was schmecken lässt sich auch
von mir ein dia genommen gesichert okay
ich gehe trotzdem dran so sehr gut
dann brauche ich hab ja genug eisen habe
ich doch genug und neiße sachen und ich
brauche was soll ich mir nehmen 42 stück
danke dir alter so will ich jetzt so was
von safe bei dem was ich vorhabe leute
ich bin ja auf dem blatt magic trip ist
er und ich habe vor loszuziehen ein
williger dorf zu finden und für den
black magic alter level 2 brauchen wir
nämlich in emerald und ich dachte mir
okay farben finde ich niemals in
emmerich und deshalb hatte ich einfach
vor den den so zu suchen
frage mich wo ist die chance ist die
frage
ok macht das ja das ist einfach verdammt
ich hab ich hatte gehofft dass es mit
einem sommer entscheidet geht aber
aber so richtige bücherregale gibt es ja
auch nicht alleine da vorne ist das
wasser das heißt ich werde jetzt einfach
in diese richtung hier loslaufen leute
so die koordinaten der stadt noch ein
letztes mal screenshot und jetzt begebe
ich mich auf die reise leute mein ziel
sind sechs federn ein emerald und später
dann der net das ist nicht so richtig
spannend habe ich irgendwas gefühl da
vorne sind schon da sind schon etliche
komischen mops lohnes drei verpassen die
mir aber tut dank einem perfekten kicker
schwertner roma in europa reisen
russland habe ich schon ja also so ganz
gefährlich wirds nicht ok ich hab' ich
habe es nur noch ich glaube das habe ich
alles mitgenommen wie viel hast du dir
genommen
gemeint ist 24 stimmt nicht mehr gut
abkommen sich vielleicht auch langweilig
meint ich hatte 30
jetzt sind nur noch 11 ich hab mir
wirklich so 34 genommen nein nein hält
poison von basteln die zurück geht
zurück die jetzt vom was kriegt ein paar
okay ist es vorbei hält dieses motech
macht mich verrückt ich krieg plötzlich
pausen von irgendwas
ja das kann sein natürlich da ist eine
willige grab statue die baue ich mir ab
vielleicht kommt irgendwas meistens raus
gutes nicht mal mittwoch nicht will
warte mal da könnte doch ein
zusammenhang bestehen oder als teenager
statue
das könnte könnte tatsächlich sein das
wäre der wahnsinn leute oh gott ich weiß
nicht ob irgendeiner schon mal so auf
erkundungstour gegangen ist
ich bin fit ich habe mich im
singleplayer maps stelle gebe ich mir
das zach-team was sich aktuell in der
folge habe ich habe hier schon mal ein
paar kühe
damit dürfte ich dann auch wirklich ja
eben damit dürftig schaffen
hey ich hab schon wieder so ein mega
stranger vergiftung
diesen schaden ja okay da vorne ist
zucker okay dass das leute ist jetzt
schon mal meine minimap versprochen so
zac so papier leder und buch ist am
start buch kompass atlas reinschauen
ok damit damit seht ihr schon mal leute
das hier ist die karte und damit sehe
ich jetzt schon mal wo ich mich gerade
bewege hier ist nirgendwo ein ja ein
williger dorf gerade aktuell das heißt
ich muss mich leider noch weiter bewegen
meine folge schon bei sieben minuten ich
bin eigentlich relativ viertel also
stichwörter aufgenommen habe
ja das ist das ist echt kritisch ich
hoffe also die die absolute hühner
perfekt perfekt komm schon weiß wie ich
nur eins eine feder
23 ich brauch sechs federn bitte lasst
sie doch alle keine federn dienten
missgeburten ich hab zwei federn die
hunde ok alter wie schnell verliere ich
essen ist es auf hart eingestellt
irgendwie schon wieder kein dicker ich
habe vier fehlern jetzt von 1000
hühnchen gefühlt aber du hast ja auch
noch eine ja okay dann bewege ich mich
jetzt einfach mal weiter es liegt hier
wirklich ein bisschen und ich glaube
dieses dieses modul sag ich mal dieses
gebiet des bio wo ich gerade bin ist
bekannt für diese flächen in los angeles
für diese ich weiß gar nicht genau wie
die dinger heißen diese irgendwie aus
wie so star wars flugzeuge wie diese
schon wieder kein billiger dorfwirt ich
laufe jetzt einfach noch eine ganze
weile gaal aus weil ich brauche die
switche dorf patrick hat auch schon
seine ganzen folgen gemeint und so viel
darf ich glaub ich sagen auch du hast in
der ganzen zeit kein billiger dorf
gefunden und es gestaltet sich so
schwierig so ein verdammtes villiger
dorf zu finden
okay was ist das was ist das bitte
billiger.de es gefunden oh mein gott ich
werde nicht sterben und es ist ein
riesiges dorf
was habe ich für ein glück leute was
haben wir für ein glück man sagt was man
will und es passiert alter es ist so
epic das könnte tatsächlich sein ich
meine ich weiß nicht ob die dinger nur
von den wirklichen billiger stirbt aber
es würde sinn machen irgendwie ich frage
mich ob es ein bisschen doof ist mein
und was was man die wälder so bitte ich
muss nur mit dem 2017 schicken ein
emerald ich hab 11 die kommen schon kaum
schon das ist halt so ein heftiger die
22 kohle ein emerald kaum schuldig ich
habe keine kohle dabei komm schon 16
wolle ein engel sind solche fucking
lächerlichen trades erstmal die
koordinaten screenshot so gibt's hier
kohle drin 22 kohle ist eigentlich das
siehst du weißt ja gut das könnte ich
halte sie machen aber ich habe angst
leute ich bin jetzt schon lang auf der
direkt neben neben dem ding ist
die hier ist ein entscheid dollar ich
glaube ich reck den und hat etwas
gebracht
komisches zeug rastet ein running gag ok
bauleute das ist das ist nicht das also
du könntest
ich würde suchen das ist glaube ich echt
das beste vertritt aber ich sehe hier
gerade keine direkt und da vorne
ich glaub kohle findet also ich hab noch
neun minuten kohle dürftig finden aber
22 zeit trotzdem wieder eine ader
erreicht stimmt schon
da sind diese sasquatch mitgestalten
zwar sind die sie dank der schwärze dann
gehe ich jetzt einfach hier in die höhle
rein
heute wünscht mir einfach glück was ist
das dessen structure structure meine ich
also eine struktur irgendwie okay
hier ist jede menge kohle ich brauch 22
ich irgendwas hinter mir mal ich irgend
was hinter mir passiert irgendwas um
mich herum und leute ist es so spannend
ist es nachts draußen ist es noch keine
nacht aber es müsste jeden moment nacht
werden kann um sekunden handeln bis
nacht wird ich hab die kohle gerade gar
nicht auf rohkost
nämlich nie aber es ist halb so wild ich
bin noch neben der hauptader die ich
gerade abgebrochen
ohne spaß bitte danke dass du dabei
weißt ich weiß nicht ob ich das alleine
schaffen würde
hier kommt schon das ist eine richtig
schöne ader so als wäre es ein junkie
und wird mir in schuss setzen leute her
damit
ich brauchte es gibt mir die kohle kohle
als recht und hassler der gleich will
diesen emmerich 31 kohle so ab nach
draußen
bitte es darf keine nacht seien jetzt
das wäre optimal direkt in die stadt
zurück zu kommen aber ich glaub ich die
folge werde ich werde ich nicht mehr in
der stadt beenden so das wäre zu heftig
so kommt bitte finde ich jetzt den
willicher wieder komm einfach zu mir
bruder gib mir den fucking emerald mehr
will ich nicht plötzlich an zu regnen
18 weizen gibt er mir immelt okay
essen dürfte kein problem werden gebt
mir mein fucking [ __ ]
wo ist das stressig es regnet übel so
aber vom regner wenigstens den sound
ausgemacht das heißt aber das hält die
sind voll auf crack the village die
rasten komplett wie die sich hier wie
sich hier bewegen
die die sind auf diesem so auf speed
beruhigen beruhigen es ist noch tag aber
ich weiß weiß nicht ob ich sagen soll
ich weiß nicht ob es langsam naja ich
bin jetzt halt nicht so direkt gelaufen
aber ich glaube diese villiger dörfer
zumindest die so groß sind wie dieses
hier wo ich gerade bin haben immer so
ein gastraum wo man wo sie im bett
aufgestellt haben dann könnte ich
wahrscheinlich in die nacht definitiv
überleben
aber es wird gerade auch nicht nachts
ich bin als ich am 2
mathe videos der teams die tales wo kann
ich ja mal den regen aufmachen am rain
ist auch sehr gut als lang wegen stress
nämlich nur finde ich alles klar
und das ist auch bugs chefs die nehme
ich einfach mal mit
links vorn das werfe ich weg was wichtig
ist es immer so stress wenn ich weiß was
du wegwerfen sagt okay jetzt direkten
dungeon ich würde ja eigentlich
vorschlagen dass wir da irgendwie
zusammen reingehen
ich habe aber auch bock hier sind so
ganz viele grabfelder die abzubauen weil
das board halt manchmal gutes zeug oder
halt bücher ein slime dings habe ich
gerade bekommt eigentlich will ich das
nicht aber das zu selten marc marquez zu
bekommen zombie zombie cop bad cop ist
auch nice aber besser ist ein zombie
kopf später für blatt magic war dann
kann man so besondere effekte auf sich
selbst anwenden
ok ja gut die billiger sind auf jeden
fall meine brüder
da ist wieder der kollege der drucke ich
hole jetzt aber noch ein zweiter fall so
auch später einen brauchst du dass du
nicht noch mal selbst muss so die folge
ist 16 minuten lang
ich weiß wirklich nicht was ich jetzt
machen soll federn habe ich sieben
fehlern warteplatz eine gas trainer
bräuchte ich jetzt noch etwas zu sagen
21 bücher ja warum er hier ist ein bett
das nicht mehr mit hier sind noch mehr
bücher bitte so viele bücher wie es geht
zweiter waren noch mehr bücher alles mit
büchern
ja ja klar dann machst du einfach
wahrscheinlich so einem team entscheiden
table wohl jeder etwas haben kann
okay ich mache also richtig kennen dran
zerstörte das winzerdorf und die aktuell
als durch tut mir leid moody's hat
patrick koordinaten norma screenshot vom
dorf das sich die teilen kann
ich glaube ich habe von diesem dorf
geholt was sie brauche ich denke ich
kann mich jetzt auf den rückweg begeben
leute einfach wenn ihr auf den weg wenn
das zelt in schafbrücke und wollen
wirklich dass chillige ist ich habe
jetzt dadurch dass ich die karte habe
ist mein die dieses visum wie soll man
das beschreiben was ich normalerweise
hast du frühe siedler gezockt siedler
und da ist ja auch immer nur das quasi
im licht gewesen was wurde schon war es
und so ist das hier auch deshalb kannst
du halt mega gut den weg nachvollziehen
wenn du den du gelaufen bist um das ist
diese alten strategie spielen einfach
wasser entdeckt hast es wurde gezeigt
und anja genau genau so ist das und ich
glaube deshalb werde ich jetzt schaffen
zurückzufinden einfach den ganzen weg
hier vorne entlang 18 minuten ist die
folge jetzt hier lang
also ich hab jetzt bei den anderen
eigentlich unbekannt investors 21 masse
glauben stehen weil natürlich gesehen
die haben auch gameplay material ja
glaub ich auch er kommt sind also den
weg weg zurück dürften noch schaffen
glaube ich okay leute und wisst ihr was
das bedeutet was wir heute geschafft
haben das bedeutet nichts weniger als
dass wir nur noch einen höllen vorteil
brauchen und dort einen einzigen gas
töten damit wir halt die gas trainer
bekommen und dann können wir fliegen mit
der blut magie
das ist so also du du zahlst quasi die
jeden jeden schub den du brauchst zu
vergleichen mit diesem electric start
von von hero und jeden job den du
brauchst bezahlst du mit deiner blut
energie in lp also lebenspunkten ich
glaube wenn du deinen kompletten leben
opfers mit dem blut euch also auf ein
halbes herz und zahlst du 4001 es wird
irgendwie nicht nach das verstehe ich
überhaupt nicht ich bin jetzt 20 minuten
absolut der gleiche und 20 minuten auf
dem server und das wird noch richtig
lang sind hier also gerade zur - 2000
irgendwas ist news 2000 - 1500 bleibt
die koordinaten wir sind bei 19 minuten
45 das heißt ich habe gott ich bin schon
wieder in diesem team wo du einfach
vergiftung für nichts so kommst ja also
ich habe echt richtig gute ergebnis
bekommen also gerne sage ich ja auch die
koordinaten oder schick den screenshot
von den koordinaten
die die teile ich gerne mit dir so aber
gute sachen geschafft leute wir haben
dank patrick gerne mal bei ihm
vorbeischauen und ihm danke schön da
lassen in meinem namen wirklich das
saphir schwert bekommen das hat mir sehr
viel stress vom herzen genommen jetzt
bei der reise die wir die wir machen
mussten und so haben wir die reise
erfolgreich geschafft wir haben
buck bücher für alle geholt wir haben
jetzt insgesamt 30 bücher und weil aus
30 metern hast du zehn books machen
pastor oder wie viel braucht man um
level 30 zu entscheiden 30 ist wenn man
sich ja man kann kombinieren ich weiß
was mir okay ich sehe die stadt ich sehe
die stadt leute vor bin ich froh das ist
wie so ein richtiges homecoming tut mir
leid dass die fps die ganze sohle waren
vor der nächsten folge wenn ich mich mal
meinem pc neu starten
so aber ich werde es noch ganz schnell
in meinem ein baumhaus reinwaschen das
zeug in die kiste packen damit die
anderen auch von meinen kunden
profitieren können da ich mein und so
rein da kam schon kommt schon zu meinem
baumhaus zurück das übrigens sehr viele
von euch als extrem hässlich betitelt
haben ja klar das ist ja war ja nur in
einer halben folge kurzen gewusst aber
irgendjemand hat sich hier schon eine
stellten schütten schöne
aussichtsplattform gebaut
auch sich plattform ja so ok rain rain
mit den mit den wertvollen sachen ein
empty netter zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack zack so und ich gehe vom
server leute das war's man heutigen
folge macht's gut
wir waren mega produktiv hatten glück
bis zum nächsten mal dabei
patrick patrick